friends who do not celebrate Christmas
because they say December 25th is really
a pagan holiday while I agree that Jesus
may not have been born on December 25th
he certainly was born as described in
the Bible how do I respond to them well
in a sense tell them that right it's
that time of the year at Christmastime
what what if what if ice do you give I
mean for a lot of the new Muslims people
who have found out what the purpose of
life is they they've started to practice
Islam but it can be a little bit
challenging now the holidays come around
and with family and friends and you know
this is a whole environment that you've
grown up into what do you like to tell
words of encouragement you know getting
through this time with the family the
invitations the gifts and all these
other things that go along with it and
then sometimes even Muslims trying to
appease their their friends and
neighbors they'll even you know say hey
I'm you know I'm here with you I got a
Christmas tree Merry Christmas and you
know well you know what can we say but
no you're Dean learn the religion know
where the limits are you know Islam can
be practiced anywhere but you need to
know what you can do and what you can't
because if it's left up to you as an
individual you know our desires have no
limits so for us to get beyond those
desires we need to have proper knowledge
and learning the Dean will protect us
teach us and train us how to handle
these kinds of situations yeah you know
and there are complexities to them this
there is no one answer which we say in
that sense you just do this yeah
regardless now in most cases yeah maybe
you should do that but there are some
exceptions or some other circumstances
that are
and you know you have to weigh the the
the harm and the benefits it's not all
black and white yeah it's it's not clear
black and white all the time sometimes
it isn't you know it's easy to make a
decision but other times it's you know
their gray areas that you have to you
know maneuver your way through and
what's gonna help you make that maneuver
is knowledge yeah
knowledge of Quran and the Sunnah
because that's what it's for it is it is
our guide it is serrata mostly it's the
straight path that we pray for every day
I often tell you know our Christian
friends and you know because we all have
the same father Adam peace be upon him
we all descendants of a darkness we want
the best for everybody we that's why we
share this message appear monotheism and
you have so it's never our intent to try
to insult or to talk bad about but you
also have certain Christians who don't
celebrate Chris Christmas you have a lot
of Christians who don't celebrate it
because they see the roots of it and so
you do not celebrate Christmas because
they say December 25th is really a pagan
holiday while I agree that Jesus may not
have been born on December 25th he
certainly was born as described in the
Bible how do I respond to them well
let's tell him that right and then we
wouldn't ask Hindus to celebrate Eid
would we because Hindus
you know usually worship the cow and
we're sacrifice we're sacrificing so we
understand that so nobody should take
offense should they I mean we're not
trying to offend nobody you have more of
a right to celebrate when we have the
Eids because we're connected through
Abraham but there's no really when you
look into the the stems and the origins
of Christmas and really what it's become
now just materialism and whatnot but
it's never our our our our intention to
offend nobody I really make that point
clear but what do you have to say say
well you know it's a matter of
respecting people's right to believe or
not believe to accept or not accept it
just doesn't have to be in a in a
and yeah offensive kind of way but you
know I mean Christians should respect
our right to differ yeah
in in the belief of God having a son it
begotten son we have the right not to
accept that yeah you know actually the
majority of Christianity in the early
years after Jesus was taken up didn't
believe that this is something which
came along later it came from the Greek
and Roman traditions and backgrounds and
and they worked its way into the the
heart of Christianity but you know I
mean all you have to do is read you know
read about areas the Bishop of
Alexandria and and the Arian heresy
that's what is called Arian heresy
those Christians who didn't believe
Jesus was God and then with a majority
in the East Egypt Palestine Syria
you know Turkey these areas were Muslim
we could call it the precursors Muslims
really are the inheritors of that
tradition Wow so it's like the more you
go back to the original and that's what
we just trying to do we're trying to go
back to the pure organic way you just
mentioned something really profound the
more you go back to Jesus peace be upon
him it was pure monotheism
he never ever claimed that he was God a
literal son of God never you will not
find any there I think there's still
that challenge a million-dollar and more
challenges if anybody can bring any
evidence or authentic proof that he ever
said he's God or worship Him I think
that challenge still stands does it
itself act it's there yeah yeah but then
you mention something even more profound
even his followers after him and then
after him still there was none of this
it's later you mentioned that this and
then you people can go research this
when this started to actually
happen absolutely absolutely I mean if
one goes into the history and the
historical records you know concerning
James who there's one James that call
James the elder and James the younger
right and the Catholics they celebrate
James the elders martyrdom he was he was
killed but James the younger they then
they mix sometimes mix these two up
James
younger is the one who is described in
the texts of the Gospels as being the
brother of Christ his brother now that's
what it described it yeah it's in the it
is in the text yeah this is not
something somebody's been here from
outsider in the four Gospels it's there
he's referred to it specifically not
only that is taught they talk about
Jesus's sisters brothers and sisters is
not the only one but he became the head
of the Jerusalem church right do they
call it jus some church or you can maybe
even call him the first pope you know as
a leader of the believers who believed
in Jesus and those who came from that
tradition you know it was Paul who went
into Greece moved out of that region and
promoted the idea of divinity of Christ
but the the followers of Jesus who
remained in Jerusalem their belief was
that he was a prophet of God they did
not believe he was Jesus sorry he was
crying the son of that this is a fact
this is this is this is academically I
mean is you can go substantiate this
this is these are facts yeah hard for
their books written but you know they
don't get the kind of you know promotion
cetera but there's there's a series of
book so you can go back in the library
you know written by Christian scholars
one of them is called just James Church
that huh yeah just James yeah yeah and
he theologian he gathered the
information and in it after showing how
the followers of James and and those who
maintained the monotheistic approach
that Jesus was not God how they were
hunted down and they were killed and
their writings were destroyed etcetera
etcetera and it appeared that they were
wiped out but as he said they weren't
the inheritors are the Muslims that
belief didn't die he makes that
statement in the end in the book himself
so and he brings all the information
yeah about James so the most people
don't know about
yeah so so this is just this is this is
us keeping in that that and those
teachings of Jesus peace be upon him on
who he really was
a Messenger of God promoting the the
same message as all the other messengers
that were sent a pure monotheism so by
and and staying away from anything that
can displease God so we just stay away
from let's say because would that equal
you saying Merry Christmas does that
equal that you confirm that Jesus was
son of God died on the cross all these
other connotations that come with it
this is this is what you're confirming
that he had a birth date that he was
born etc yeah this is the this is the
problem that you know people because it
becomes such a cultural tradition you
know people no longer look at its roots
and where it came from and what it
implies and everything else it's just
no now just just television those two
words you know if that God had a son a
human being born in this world of a
woman a woman who the Catholics call the
mother of God look at that this is
blasphemy
the mother of god the god had a mother
come on man you know they have if you
read up in in in to Mary Allah tree
where they worship Mary as I got on you
have a whole traditional whole segment
of Catholicism that went into this Mary
Allah tree and in a big scale yeah Mary
was a God for them so masha'Allah you
know there's a lot of information out
there not just things written by Muslims
you know but written by Christian
scholars themselves they have shown
clearly that the Gospels that people are
calling the Gospels of Jesus are just
writings by individuals whose reality
whose whose identity were unknown
Matthew Mark Luke and John you know when
you look in the Encyclopedia Britannica
well who is this Matthew they don't know
who is Mark they don't was Luke who they
don't know who is John they don't know I
mean for most Christians I think or John
must be John the Baptist and you know
this one is that and ever but the fact
of the matter is they don't know these
are anonymous documents among many other
hundreds of other documents that are out
there they said that there are more than
fifty thousand you know man
scripts pieces of manuscripts on the god
of the Gospels no two of them agreeing
with every point ma yeah when you have
that kind of confusion scattered mix-ups
you know how can you try to draw out of
that clarity reality yeah so like this
is just to highlight those things just
so people have more awareness of what
they're saying and what they're
celebrating and this is no attacker or
or belittle the Christians or anything
this is just pointing out some obvious
facts of why we would kindly exclude for
participating we don't try to force you
know our celebrations on anyone so they
shouldn't be forced on us also or looked
upon because we're not you know saying
certain words in terms that we deem that
go ahead and offend God and would offend
Jesus we tried to make our point clear
and we just stay away from that
respectfully kindly with compassion and
love I know I don't think anybody should
take offense to that yeah the same way I
made that that example because the
Hindus for some people are no they
literally worship because that right
share now this is part you know people
are you can go to jail in India for
killing a cow so Muslims we celebrate
Eid and we will it's not the blood that
reaches God but you know we go and
distribute this meat to port the family
and we can sacrifice the lamb a cow or
whatnot so we wouldn't ask the Hindu to
to celebrate the Eid with us they would
be offended by that right so I'm just
making this making this comparison why
should people because Muslims are so
scared of offending someone and whatnot
but then they forget about offending the
most high when they fall into some of
these celebrations and I think if they
point out some of the things you've
mentioned and we talked about this will
actually be a good opening a discussion
to have to kind of you know talk about
our purpose in life and and and really
what we're here for in this life yeah